One of the interesting byproducts of the
digitization of everything is the steep
rise in nostalgia for physicality.
This is a great lecture from the writer
and publisher James Bridle,
where he laughs about the fact that
nobody ever really talked about the
smell of books until ebooks started to
threaten their existence.
All of a sudden we became nostalgic for
a quality that he never really noticed
before or take the resurgence in vinyl
record sales.
Well,
it's definitely true that the sound
quality of vinyl is amazing.
I'd be willing to bet that our
attraction to it also has something to
do with the object itself are a real
thing that takes up space in your home
as symbol of the analog world.
As more and more of our lives get
vacuumed into the digital realm,
we're increasingly likely,
I think,
to look for these symbols and be
attracted to them,
and the crazy thing is that these
reminders don't even have to be physical
objects.
All they have to do to tap into that
nostalgia is resemble the traits of
those objects.
Think about instagram filters designed
to look like old cameras and film
stocks.
These filters mimic objects that most
instagram users won't ever touch.
As bridle says,
putting a filter on your digital photo
is an attempt to codify that image as
memory to wrap it up in something solid
historical that calls back to a time
before everything was fluid and changing
and impossible to hold onto.
In this way,
our nostalgia becomes an aesthetic and
in film,
one of the features of that aesthetic is
green film.
Grain is a texture in process film that
has the appearance of tiny particles
moving around randomly in the image.
The amount of grain has to do with the
speed and size of the film stock and the
amount of light being used during the
era when film was the only choice.
Many photographers and filmmakers tried
hard to eliminate this aspect of film
processing,
but it was always a part of cinema,
especially in low budget independent
movies.
Using smaller film stocks like 16
millimeter and without access to big
professional studio lighting these days,
it's easy to tap into that India
aesthetic.
By using grain.
The grain itself is loaded with all
these associations that reached back
into the history of film.
The question is,
now that grain has its own aesthetic,
can that aesthetic be pushed further?
And that brings me to Mandy.
The second feature film from pandas
cause mottos.
If you haven't seen it,
do that right now.
It might still be playing at a local
theater near you.
Mandy is a revenge horror movie starring
Nicolas Cage,
reminiscent of the grindhouse films of
the seventies and eighties when the
movie is set.
It's a simple story as most revenge
movies are,
but what sets it apart is the
psychoactive vision and focus of cars.
Matos who clearly has something very
specific in mind.
Visually movie is dark,
grimy,
often saturated with primary colors and
completely awash in grain.
In this way,
it's not unlike cars.
Motto says first feature beyond the
Black Rainbow,
which is much more ambiguous plot wise,
but interested in exploring the same
visual fetishes for cars.
Mottos,
it's not just about paying homage to old
films.
It's about learning the expressive
potential of existing aesthetics and
stretching their qualities to see what
kinds of feelings and tones they can
evoke.
The way I look at it now though is I
feel like in the present time has no
meaning anymore and so it's.
I feel like now choosing an era fear
film is almost like choosing a color
beyond the black rainbow and Mandy
invite us to consider film grain as a
visual tool like lighting or color,
not just a byproduct of chemical
processing.
So what is green feel like and maybe the
most prominent quality of film grain is
movement.
The grain is always moving.
It's swimming,
which means that even in a still life of
let's say a flower on a table that
flowers alive,
even though it's not moving,
grain gets inside whatever's in the
frame and imbues it with motion.
In fact,
this kind of swimming,
breathing movement from within mimics
the visual effects of hallucinogenic
drugs which play a major part in mandate
film.
Grain is hypnotic and that adds to the
sense of the film existing in a
dreamlike universe or as one horribly
bad acid trip.
At times the grain almost has a paranoid
feeling like there's something squirming
under the image.
Another quality of grain is that it
blends grain,
gives an underlying texture to the frame
so that there is a continuity between
one object and another.
It gives the impression that the image
is atomized into tiny particles that
could disperse and overlap because most
often mixes heavy grain with smoke to
heighten this effect for the characters
and the viewers.
Nothing is solid or what it seems things
can shift at a moment's notice.
In a world that looks like this,
you're always vulnerable,
always at risk of coming apart.
The most striking example of this is a
scene in the first half of Mandy.
Mandy herself is kidnapped by a cult and
force fed hallucinogenic drugs cause
mottos turns the dial way up on the
scene by drenching the image in purple
and pink hues and adding a trailing
effect to movement so that when the cult
leader,
Jeremiah sands just stimulates,
you actually have this steam of grain
that falls away from Christ life.
Then when he kneels down to speak to her
up close,
because mottos actually feeds Mandy's
face into sands,
it's hardly noticeable at first and
that's purposeful.
The texture of the image helps this be
so subtle that you're not quite sure if
your mind is playing tricks on you.
It's important to know that even though
this is cool as hell and something that
film geeks like myself drool over,
this effect is not just visual
decoration.
It adds to the story.
Sands is trying to assimilate mandy into
his coat.
As you see her face feed into his,
he's using the qualities of psychoactive
drugs to loosen Mandy's grip on her own
identity so that he can substitute his
own stuff like this is what gives mandy
it's power.
It's the aesthetic is not added onto the
film after the fact.
It's a film that literally wouldn't
function if you took those aesthetic
features away.
That's true for its use of film grain
and for all the other visual fireworks
of the movie.
You know,
his history becomes nostalgia and
nostalgia becomes aesthetic.
A great opportunity is being presented
to new filmmakers.
I agree with cars,
mottos,
time has no meaning anymore.
Every aesthetic of the past is a Palette
for the future.
You can copy and paste those old
aesthetics onto your work or you can
take up the colors with a spirit of
experimentation and have some fucking
fun.
How you doing?
Everybody?
Thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
skillshare and online learning community
for creators with more than 18,000
classes and everything from graphic
design and film editing to finance and
it security.
You know what?
I learned photoshop.
I learned it through a mishmash of
disconnected youtube videos and I can't
help but feel that the process would
have gone a lot faster if there was a
class dedicated to teaching me
everything about that program in a
systematic way.
Learning new skills is super valuable to
me because whenever I learned a new
skill,
it's like a bunch of new ideas are
suddenly unlocked in my head.
I think what can I do with this?
And that always,
always helps me with writer's block.
A premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses,
but the first 500 people to sign up
using the link that's right below in the
description,
get their first two months for free.
In those two months,
you could easily learn the skills you
need to start a new hobby or business.
More importantly,
the skills you learn will help give you
the ideas for what that business or our
project could be.
Definitely try it out.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.